Joseph Stalin secret police chief once
famously proclaimed quote show me the
man I'll show you the crime now those
are chilling words and the opposite of
how the American justice system is
supposed to operate our system is
designed to prosecute crimes not
persecute individuals we disagree with
we live in a constitutional republic
we're supposed to have equal justice
under the law and the equal application
of our laws tonight in the United States
this is all in jeopardy after more than
15 months of intensive investigations
surrounding one man the President of the
United States more and more americans
rightly are realizing that Muller's
seemingly never-ending witch hunt is not
only damaging the country but it is
rocking our system of justice to its
very core and following the New York
Times so-called bombshell report that
the White House attorney the president's
attorney in other words White House
Counsel Tom McGann is cooperating with
the Special Counsel investigation the
president tweeted this quote disgraced
is credited Bob Muller in his whole
group of angry Democratic thugs spent
over 30 hours with the White House
Counsel only with my approval for the
purposes of transparency anybody needing
that much time when they know there's no
Russian collusion is just someone
looking for trouble they're enjoying
ruining people's lives and refused to
look at the real corruption on the
Democratic side the lies the firings the
bleated emails and so much more Muller's
angry Democrats are looking to impact
the election a national disgrace so far
25 top FBI DOJ officials have either
been fired demoted or resigned Wow Newt
Gingrich is out with a brand-new op-ed
it raises this important point quote it
couldn't be more clear the Trump White
House was comfortable talking for 30
hours with a pack of high-powered very
tough-minded investigators because the
president has done nothing wrong
my sources say by the way this took
place over a period of time a while ago
and according to a brand new report from
the Washington Post McGann does not
believe he implicated the truck
in legal wrongdoing and special counsel
interviews his attorney tells the
president's legal team for months team
Muller has unsuccessfully tried to turn
the screws on multiple individuals only
because of their association with Trump
in other words we're criminalizing
political differences they wanted
something anything they could use to get
the president and instead of finding
evidence of any Russian collusion team
Muller was only able to strong-arm their
way to a couple of guilty pleas let's
see lying to investigators the FBI
didn't think they lied 2005 tax fraud
case Paul Manafort nothing to do with
collusion nothing to do with Russia
nothing to do with the campaign nothing
to do with Trump we're reading about
today Michael Kohn and taxi cabs this is
what you need to understand no Muller
and neither of these men Michael Kohn or
Paul Manafort would have to deal with
this no Russia no collusion no campaign
no Trump involvement we'll have a lot
more of that coming up throughout the
hour but first we do have new
information surrounding one of those
guilty pleas george papadapolis remember
he was the one-time volunteer foreign
policy advisor for the Trump campaign
this guy is facing up to six months in
jail again lying to the Muller
investigation according to a report by
renew your cat appears Papadopoulos who
was in his 20s not only played a small
role in the campaign I followed this
campaign closely I'd never heard of them
but also played a small role in Muller's
ongoing witch-hunt
in fact Papadopoulos has not been
charged with any crime related to Russia
collusion campaign conspiracy but his
life is now turned upside down and just
like manna fort and others
it looks like Michael cone we're gonna
plenty more on that story his wife will
join us tonight now let's turn to
another update from the Muller target
Paul mana for jury deliberations still
under way three full days now in the
2005 bank fraud case the media is now
looking at this as the trial of the
century it's not Manta for facing 18
counts and a potential life in prison
over charges that had nothing to do with
Russia collusion the campaign or Donald
Trump see a pattern here
metaphor Papadopoulos others they have
just become pawns
really just pawns in Robert Muller's
effort to take down the president they
wouldn't be in any trouble if these
people were not associated with Donald
Trump if man if Muller didn't exist so
you see where this is going and as judge
Ellis noted during Manta Ford's trier
trial Muller is clearly turning the
screws in this case on mana Ford so that
he will sing or compose in other words
so the witch-hunt can prosecute or
impeach Donald Trump of course Robert
mullahs just picking up where his fellow
deep state sycophant john brennan left
off for months we've reported on
Brennan's abuse of power and specific
allegations that as a CIA director
Brennan disseminated Hillary's dirty
Russian dossier throughout the federal
government and tonight Sarah Carter has
a brand new report detailing
congressional allegations that Brennan
may have been responsible now forgetting
that dossier - then Senator Harry Reid
who then subsequently released its
details to the public visa vie a letter
to James Comey and Brennan of course is
denying these claims
now we also called out Brennan's recent
conspiracy peddling about a sitting US
president during his time as a quote
MSNBC conspiracy theorist hack and last
week president Trump's trip Brennan's
security clearance rightfully so because
the CIA please pay attention policy is
clear it says this in the case of former
CIA directors the agency holds their
security clearance they renew it every
five years for the rest of their lives
however this is the important part the
however part that requires former CIA
directors to behave like current CIA
employees oh you mean like calling the
president a traitor and accusing him of
being compromised by Russia and all
sorts of bizarre conspiracies that they
peddle over them in vessel BC Brennan
was obviously in violation of that
policy it's not in question
he actually accused the sitting
president of treason and worse he's used
the status to legitimize what are absurd
absurd conspiracy claims about Donald
Trump on national TV even fellow Trump
hater James clapper this is even too
much for him
he questioned the level of Britain's
daily vitriol take a look do you think
that John Brennan's hyperbole is an
issue here it's one of the reasons we're
having this crisis well III think it is
I think mail John is sort of like a
freight train and he's gonna say what's
on his mind
I think though that the common
denominator among all of us that have
been speaking up though is genuine
concern about the Jeopardy or threats to
our institutions and values and although
we may express that in in in different
ways and I think that's what this this
really is about but John and his
rhetoric have become I think an issue in
and of itself yeah that's kind of even
clapper says that former chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff retired Admiral
Michael Mullen also criticized Brennan's
rhetoric calling it damaging to the
Intel community I'll take it a step
further and the country take a look
John's an extraordinary servant of the
country but I think he has been
incredibly critical of the president and
and I think that has put him in a
political place which actually does more
damage for the intelligence community
which is a political even as he's
retired so I really don't support him
being as critical a president as he has
been Admiral Mullen did not endorse
Trump's decision as trip Brennan's
clearance okay reasonable people have
reasonable disagreements but it is clear
Brennan's rhetoric alone is not fitting
of a current CIA employee and he's a
former director he's now threatening to
sue the Trump administration this I beg
happens sue John sue please take a look
well I have been contacted by a number
of lawyers and they have already given
me their thoughts about the basis for a
complaint and injunction to try to
prevent him from doing this in the
future if my clearances and my
reputation as I'm being pulled through
the mud now if that's the price we're
going to pay to prevent Donald Trump
from doing this against other people to
me it's a small price to pay
so I am going to do whatever I can
personally to try to prevent these
abuses in the future and if it means
going to court I will I will do that
go take I'd love to see that discovery
unless you use bleach pit and hammers
and anyway give us a perfect opportunity
to see what's going on inside all of
this by the way in terms of corruption
and by the way malignant efforts to
literally impact a presidential election
let's get it all exposed the people need
to know now today President Trump mocked
Brennan's hollow threats he tweeted out
quote I hope John Brennan the worst CIA
director in our country's history will
bring a lawsuit it will be very easy to
get all of his records texts emails and
documents to show not only the poor job
he did but how he was involved with the
Muller rigged witch-hunt he won't sue I
don't think he will either now whether
or not he actually does he's just one of
many former ranking government officials
who leveraged their special security
status yeah for financial gain
in fact it pays to have a security
clearance now upon leaving office well
we have discovered on this show and
there's actually a new book out we're
gonna break it all tomorrow many
high-ranking officials use their special
status to gain lucrative offers from
government contractors and others
seeking their expertise and meanwhile
over fake news CNN proud bleep Holder
himself Phil Mudd is profiting off his
security clearance he paid at CNN he's
an analyst got a complete meltdown when
he was challenged over what is a
lucrative practice among many that have
top security clearances not saying him
but millions of dollars Jim call me take
a look when I am requested to sit on an
advisory board let me ask you one
question how much do you think I'm paid
to do that at the request of the US
government give me one answer and you've
got ten seconds how much I'll give I'll
ask you a question how much are you paid
for your answer the question gig for for
being a contract with the US government
that pay my not to here on this one you
have a security can you keep it laid
ships with the private sector that
involve my security clearance zero I get
well
dollars from consulting companies that
deal with US government are we clear
well I will be clear and saying that
everybody in Washington DC knows if you
don't want to be honest about it that's
on you but if you have a security
clearance and you keep it you don't get
out till it's not your show Comey we're
going to talk about him tomorrow what if
I told you that there are people that
have security clearances and got paid by
Lockheed Martin and six million dollars
just pulling out out of thin air
we'll have a full report tomorrow we're
not saying Phil Mudd is involved in this
in any way we're not even saying it's
nefarious but we are saying people with
security clearances there is a money
trail and by the way tomorrow night we
will have a full investigation a Hannity
investigation investigating the
investigators follow the money
Hannity investigation back in 2013
mainstream media was largely silent when
the Obama administration by the way did
the whole same thing on a much larger
scale a blatant media double standard
but as we get closer and closer to the
most important midterm elections of our
life you got to expect this coverage is
gonna get more insane day by day minute
by minute
for example conspiracy TV MSNBC one
panelist even suggested the president
wanted to round up people and murder
them conspiracy take a look your
argument that he's not the leader of the
free world because he's not beating up
democracy he's a sort of junior player
in a block of authoritarian country and
no and then people like the European
Union are no longer looking at him as a
leader any longer and I think it's not
saying that him is right they see he's
instead he's like right he's part of a
block that includes Vladimir Putin to
tear teh he's you know but he's kind of
part of a he's part of kind of an
accident that's what it's worse than
reading it in a certain way I mean not
that that's not the worst thing you
could have said cuz it's about the worst
thing you'd say about him but rounding
people up and murdering murdering them
without any
you know you process certainly like to
you'd like to and it goes on and on
highway if the conservative said that
about Obama oh here come the Welcome the
boycotters here they come
meanwhile professional trumpeter an old
friend I actually like Steve thrashing
Trump supporters kind of does it every
day now take a look his base is smaller
the Republican Party is smaller but it
is more faithful and more intense in its
loyalty to Trump and forty percent of
the country has surrendered their
intellectual sovereignty to Donald Trump
there is for them no such thing as
objective truth anymore what is true is
what the leader says is true what the
leader believes is true and Trump has
exercised that power and forty percent
of the country has submitted themselves
to it little over the top the rhetoric
is even worse in the Democratic Party
got one congressman old friend of the
show so-called joking about what
drowning President Trump in the Potomac
if you don't want this man the
Democratic Party taking control of your
Congress blocking the president you
voted for his agenda and putting an end
to the all-important deep state
investigations you want open borders
Obamacare oh you want to give them your
crumbs back and everything in between
then don't go out and vote in November
in the midterms don't take it seriously
I like our Democratic Republic is
hanging in the balance or anything now
before we get to our guests freaking
just moments ago during an interview
with Reuters the president said he is
concerned that an interview with the
special counsel could actually be a
perjury trap I could not agree more why
they're gonna say you disagree with your
lawyer oh now what Rudy was saying
yesterday I think he could have been a
little more articulate when he said the
truth is not the truth meaning if let's
say Tom McGann says one thing president
says another thing guess who decides
which version they want to believe I
would be Muller and Weissman genie
writing and the rest of all not a good
idea